okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about a topic about
graphics the issue is the following if
we make so let's make an example here so
if we say table of labelled I squared
comma i I goes up to 10 and then we say
whoops oh that's interesting
okay and if we say list plots of that
then look at those points labeled right
however if we say graphics of labeled um
let's say point
make a table here um table labeled
points let's say I I squared
um comma I um
I up to five or something right this is
not gonna work right this is the nub of
what we're talking about people agree
yes um and I want to put this in does
anybody know where I should put this do
we have a as there are graphics over
it's visualization let's put it in that
okay um okay all right okay so this is
the issue so how could we make this work
do we want to make this work I think we
want to make this work because I think
people will assume that it works and I
don't understand why if you're gonna say
well we're not doing anything like that
I would point out to you that if I do
this okay and I say something like you
know AXYZ goes to true right it is not
the case that we're not having
annotation in graphics if you understand
what I'm saying
I mean I think the better example of
that is tooltip which like okay fine
fine so let's try this I mean I you know
maybe this some okay
so there we go right okay so let's talk
about what's involved in making this
work and maybe this is just an
implementation discussion I mean does
anybody think this shouldn't work anyway
depends on what you mean by work and the
list plot right you know it's not always
putting the label in the same place
there's some automation going on exactly
just like there is with the axes yes
there's also there is automation going
on with the axes yes like for example
the fact that that axis origin went
through zero was a piece of automation
right I think it actually went through
five but oh really well that's stupid
then okay so in any case um and you know
the choice of what to put on the axes
the axes labels and so on okay so let's
but go back to this well so yes the fact
is that it requires graphics to have a
post processing pass and I assume we had
people from the front end team here like
yeah we have John here right
we have Chonan you too yeah okay so I
mean I'm assuming that this would
actually have to happen in in the front
end rather than you know that this
graphics would be passed symbolically as
tooltip is if I'm understanding
correctly great works for me meeting
done right so so I guess right so the
tooltip type sets into a tooltip box or
does it not typeset into a tooltip box
inside of graphics
I think it's still a tool tip box right
gone folks do want to comment on this
the sorry I was looking for document
first and documentation related to some
stuff we've done the front end and I
wasn't what was the question okay so it
has to do with how tool tip is
implemented in the front end is this Oh
turning into a tool tip box
yes so so there are a very few boxes
which are supported so the the way boxes
work is their Box contexts and and the
three contexts are the 2d graphics 3d
graphics and typesetting and most boxes
will only work in their own context and
they just completely failed to do
anything useful in any other context but
there are a very small number and it's
small because it's not easy to do of
boxes that work in every context tool
tip is one tool tool tip box and tag box
is another and in fact it isn't even in
the case the button boxes one despite
the fact that button is implemented in
graphics we implemented button using
tagged box so hold on so what you're
saying that but what you're saying is if
I were to do the following if I were to
say here instead of this I would say
text and then I were to put a button in
here what's happening that I think use
of text backwards yes
ooo there's supposed to be a coordinate
okay yeah well so in so in this case it
actually changed the contexts by you
know that that's in a typesetting
context okay fine the third sense so
what sense did oh through an inset okay
so in what sense does is button support
it natively so if you wrap button around
like disk or something like that
okay I didn't know that worked well it
works by constructing an event handler
and event handlers are internally
implemented using tag boxes okay so if I
say button around here um so what we
want something larger than a point and
unless you change point size okay let's
say disk okay so you're saying that this
will have a button action yes I stay
there see what happens if I say print I
hope just says I I see because the
buttons are hold on yeah fine
okay so we'd have to do the crazy with I
equals I type yeah exactly by the way
it's not obvious we shouldn't have met a
construct for that oh wait a minute
that's oh yeah oh ma keep in mind
there's a Z order yeah I understand yes
done so if I go up there okay fine so
that's an example of Ling working okay
yeah but but but that's not implemented
using button box that is implemented
using tag box
which is used to construct event
handlers that mimic the functionality of
a button okay okay so let's come back
around to I mean what are we what are we
actually talking about we're talking
about we're talking about okay so
constructs that we are interested in are
labeled whoops labeled call out what
else Brett you had mentioned highlighted
oh yeah okay and what about legend dead
yeah probably that too if you're doing
labeled and call out there might be
others I mean there's all sorts of
rappers like framed and
um I mean like style at work I mean if I
were to do this in in this thing here if
I were to say instead of that I would
say I mean this plot doesn't support
framed yeah right so that's what I'm
talking about is the stuff that lets
plot supports right so those are the I
mean this plot doesn't support
highlighted either
um but you heads you know Santino
highlighted should graphics no but okay
maybe it should work okay so look we've
got a list of things here okay pop-up
window does that work in graphics right
now
yes status window status area and
basically everything except call-out and
labeled are in that list because they
were already supported by graphics okay
so the difference is that that labeled
and call-out actually affect the canvas
the actual graphics you know graphics
canvas but these other things are all
side effect II is that right correct
well except for style which is a little
bit different I mean it's you mean it
doesn't effect through you know space
you know it doesn't affect plot range
calculations for example yeah I
understand I understand so the biggest
sue is to put in labeled and call out
which would affect plot range
potentially and I strongly think we
should do it so I would like to hear the
issues yeah I mean you know we should do
it and it would have to be supported in
the front end which means that the
algorithms that you've I mean both in
the desktop and cloud front end that the
algorithms you have for for figuring out
where labels go and so on would have to
be ported there making sense well maybe
maybe not maybe they come up with
different algorithms no but that's not
going to work because then the question
is in the case of list plot do we leave
it so that these things are being I mean
list plot is generating a graphic object
right and Todd is inserting a plot range
into it at least when necessary
in this example the create plot this
plot calculates a plot range to embed in
the in the graphics when necessary okay
but so if we were to do something like
this let me try this um here and instead
of this I would say I factorial okay so
it successfully as positioning those I
mean notice that it did did some fancy
footwork there to position these things
easy so I mean if I say I'm interesting
okay so notice it's not cutting that
thing off at the top which means it
probably had to the fact that it left
that extra space up above the 10 I bet
if I don't have the labeled here I'm
whoops if I have them yeah it leaves a
little bit of extra spirit of padding
when there are labels okay but that's
it's not the same yeah it looks like it
might be the same okay all right okay
fine fine all right so let's continue
again what what are the issues in
getting this to work in graphics I mean
is it the case that we imagine I mean or
we could imagine a situation in which
call out and labeled evaluate in
graphics what what do we think John do
you have
so I mean you know much is so so we have
something right now that is able to to
allow you to specify you know how to
attach an object to another object in a
graphics and it's it's something that
we've you know we've actually used and
shipped that's but but we've never
shipped the thing directly but we should
have some technology built on top of it
some versions of graph used it it's
called dynamic location and the for
reasons which were not entirely clear to
me but also not incredibly surprising
apparently the graph folks moved away
from using it the I mean essentially
what it does is it says you know I have
an object and I want to be able to do
things like understand what its
perimeter is you know or or what its
center is or something like that and
then I want to place another object
relative to that object center perimeter
you know scaled coordinates away from it
or something like that and so that's a
thing that we can do now it you know it
has issues but we can do now but but
then there might be other requirements
that you might ask which start to get
much much more difficult like preventing
labels from overlaying okay right right
right the label placement algorithm is
not something we want to lose I mean we
just spent a bunch of effort making the
label placement algorithm work well for
let's plot the question is we're not
going to have something where you know
the label placement is great and let's
plot and soon as you put something in
graphics it doesn't work that's that's
why I asked my question you know I mean
unfortunately it does seem to be the
case that to figure out where the labels
go you have to have a global view of
what's in the graphic because for
example in this case one is not worry
I think about well about you know what
happens if one of these points is bigger
how do I make one of those points bigger
flood star goes to absolute point size
of ten no that's not what I want I want
them different sizes
for example I mean can I do that I can
can I get absolute points I survived
when you generate the table right well
no that's not that's not right because
that that won't do it for this case
stealing you open the documentation for
bubble chart
and scroll down there should be some
labeling examples not notes scope
labeling and legend ding
those are boring those are all looking
boring um others do Wow what's that
doing so that is from an option that we
have the controls with the maximum size
of a label is if you look at the one
below it then yeah hey by the way sorry
this is a point who's who's who's coming
here um do we have some project manager
here um okay
here also yeah okay um so socially can
you make a note that in the discussion
about held expression manipulation
mm-hmm we should discuss the width x
equals x idiom yeah it's uh okay great
so the next one has you know shows the
fall labels okay and what happened I
were labeling size because to fall I
didn't know we had all these mechanisms
okay alright but if I were to try and do
that this is labeling so it's making a
choice and whether it's using a call-out
or a or a write it on top type label is
that correct correct
is that a labeled thing there so these
are all call-outs with an automatic
position okay and and it's also
determining whether to use alright so
look the basic bottom line is it's
pretty complicated and if you in general
I mean if I were to make a bubble chart
okay so obviously I need to try this so
if I were to say here I were to make a
bubble chart and I were to put hold on
um just an abstract bubble chart here
but I would just say labeled
in that bubble chart right so um so
let's say here I say bubble chart and
each one is right so random triple well
I was thinking it's got that coordinate
how does this work
kiss at the coordinate and then the size
is that correct right and then 11 and
then a label okay so then let's say I
put an eye therefore label okay right
and all those labels are small and they
all fit inside the disks okay okay so
let's go enough kind of kind of
beautiful but but irrelevant switch to
random word I've already gotten a
soother okay so you choose to do that
are you in fact getting all the digits
here I don't think it is I think it's it
looks like it's clipping because I think
the text is centered okay so that's a
little bit embarrassing great okay so
you're just putting for label just
putting everything on top here right
I mean in bubble charts I think had
support for labeled from you know from
the start and then call out came later
okay so if I were to do all right but my
main point here is so in this case if I
were to say call out here okay beautiful
why does it do that that seems kind of
crazy why does it do it
why does it put some of them inside
because if they fit and they you know
but I heard being obscured by anything
then that's you know sort of guaranteed
space that they're not going to
interfere with anything else I mean I
asked for a call out here hmm that
doesn't look like a call out to me call
out is very general okay all right
it's a little odd looking this I mean is
there a way I can say make them always
exterior call-outs appearance that the
appearance option to call out okay it
might do it some of them saying no it's
not possible right I don't think so okay
I don't think I wanted to contradict
amend okay that's right so as the option
to call out do appearance goes to and
see whatever the completions are say
leader rest of it okay I think it's a
bit uncommon see I think this a little
bit of a bug here but but okay the main
point is there are complicated
algorithms to determine what goes where
and the question is if we're going to
implement these for graphics how does
that work those graphics have to simply
see that it has one of these things
inside and go through an evaluation pass
to figure out how to place it or do we
think it should be done in the front end
well I mean certainly not all of the
options to the VIS functions are also
options to graphics so it would be kind
of weird I understand but this this kind
of which ones are what are examples
would or not
well like label exclusions you know what
plot spell doesn't make a lot of sense
for graphics because I mean
there's a lot of options I mean
hopefully you know almost all of them
are in that category Fitz yeah a better
example perhaps you know and touching
back on what we discussed you know we're
looking at earlier is like the plot
legends option which is supported by viz
functions but not graphics okay
hey why didn't this work the leader
thing I mean what why does it it's just
overriding that and deciding that that
it goes best here so I'm putting the
labels inside the bubbles will save up a
space for other labels so if there is a
complicated bubble chart that will now
save up space yes I mean I would still
expect it to override yeah I think this
I think this is a bug I think if you
explicitly say you know give an
appearance option it should do that now
it can it and I don't know what call-out
is documented to do the default is
automatic for what the appearance is but
but none of those appearances represent
I mean if I say balloon here I mean none
of those appearances say put it inside
the object right the position was
decided first and then the appearance
was on top of that right it's basically
switching between leader and none okay
also changing the position but but so if
you say a parents are none then what
does it do it looks like a label okay I
mean that this is really confusing
because this said I want balloons but
that isn't a balloon big round thing
isn't a balloon yeah um okay but but so
right i mean that that i think this is
not right but this not that's not really
the subject of the discussion here
correct
um I mean so I mean I'm not sure what
the solution is or that it's even
necessarily a single pronged thing right
I mean so if we to me there are two
possible solutions one solution is that
graphics when it contains call-out and
labeled does an evaluation pass and
produces something where those are
resolved before it passes it to the
front end or thing number two we have
these capabilities in the front end
right
so I actually a number of interesting
comments on the live stream here which I
want to look at so one person is
commenting that full graphics has been
broken since version six gosh that's so
it's probably been broken since longer
than that that's showing cut well what
what is I don't even know do we even
document full graphics anymore I think
we still document for graphics but not
full options my gosh well that's pretty
embarrassing what happened here so do we
think this should work and what what is
the story here what was the point of
full graphics well I mean the most
ordinary case I was aware of was to get
axes and and frames to be explicitly in
the graphics so that you could
manipulate them in some way typically
that was maybe less convenience using
options what you think so in other words
to actually resolve out but how does
that right to absolute options and so on
it doesn't not not for this sort of
thing absolute options which is which is
not working like it should but even if
it was working like it should it
wouldn't do that
it would you know absolute options would
turn automatic into explicit values but
it would still be the actual values of
the options not the equivalent graphics
primitives I understand I understand so
that what that's doing is its resolving
what the effective I'm sure it was tics
are automatic as the default but this is
resolving what that means if you were to
specify it precisely as opposed to make
this into a bunch of line segments right
so what we're talking about is an
automatic full first of all the fact the
full graphics doesn't work is kind of
embarrassing but the first question my
guess is that something happened when we
walked away from the PostScript
generation and the kernel I guess but
this is outrageous that there weren't
any tests that picked us up and so on
and I'd completely forgotten about this
funk well as I as we mention it I I
remember I remember it but it's some wow
that's that's really um right okay
somebody is typing um the what what
should we do with full graphics how
difficult would it be to make it work
properly I think it's actually I think
related to work that know what Aaron was
doing for class yeah no it is a
front-end question because the front end
is the sole arbiter these days of these
kinds of renderings and we do have in
the front end we do have this you know
convert to input form thing which might
be co-opted to do something along these
lines is that the Jason graphics thing
or is that some things it's it's related
it actually predates the json graphics
by a considerable degree but it it's
using many of the
same mechanisms but in this case
emitting wolf and language input form
rather than JSON so how would I get that
what do I do that so I can go convert to
input for me so yeah yeah I think if you
just select a cell with a graphic and
convert it I'm not for sure if that will
work or not if it doesn't that can give
you an example I mean that's not going
to change the axes and stuff
yeah that's not that's not resolving the
axis okay
but but so okay so that's another thing
we got to figure out it's full graphics
I mean and I mean it's a related thing
you know so if it isn't handled by the
front end labeled and call out in
whatever then in order to support you
know the full range of primitives
yeah so we're disk specs and you know
various splines and whatever else then
you need some way of getting position
information about those objects right
[Music]
and so I mean if you want it fully
general you know it either has to be in
the front end or but you say you're
saying if you want it to be able to deal
with different sizing of fonts and all
that kind of stuff then that is only no
and at rendering time is that correct
well I mean fonts and you know how big a
disk is and that sort of thing okay let
me ask a question for you Bret how
complicated is all this code that
determines the placement of labels and
so on is it a big hairy mess or is it
fairly clean what is it is it Wolfram
language code it is Wolfram language
code
and is it consumers is it conceivable
it's compiled herbal by the compiler
no I not anytime soon okay you mean
portions of it might be so the only
realistic way that that code would be
usable in the front end is with a
callback right okay which is effectively
equivalent to doing a pre-processing
pass on the graphics the only question
is what we would store so right now in
graphics we're storing that cache right
remember and what we have I mean it like
if I do this plot here and I will not
the input for mothers typing in not on
you please mute themselves or something
um the you know if I look at the at this
right what is this cache here what is
that thing that's not a cache that's the
line it's a packed array yeah that's a
peccary okay store this compress data
okay all right so then my question would
be if what about the following
possibility that we actually pre-process
the graphics in the kernel and then send
along to the front end the something
which contains caching data that has the
information about how to place these
things rather than modifying the actual
graphics object which I don't think is a
good idea
I think the graphics object has to you
know you know continue to be inert right
I mean I guess there's a question of can
we actually compute this without leaking
side-effects which would still be a
problem for people who actually
manipulate graphics okay well that's a
different issue but I don't think most
of the stuff has okay but if there is a
side-effect associated with the
computation of a label
well III I don't think that's an issue
but but maybe I'm wrong
so the algorithm does you know some
amount of can I get an understanding of
the structural issue if right if if
graphics is not is okay it's basically
generating caching data that it can sent
to the front end it does not affect when
you type graphics in the kernel that
graphics object as far as the visible
thing is concerned will be completely
inert however the kernel will be
generating a hidden cache that it can
send to the front end that specifies the
placement of those things so that we're
not recomputing or computing you know
having to compute in the front end all
of this placement information j'onn
faults can you comment on that
um sorry I was still looking at the
input form thing which I'm very close to
having by the way it's it looks like we
we do have the the ability to really
literal eyes axes and such okay so fine
so then we can re implement so then that
can be put into full graphics and we can
fix that bug yeah okay so now can you
pay attention to this please so one
proposing is that what we do is that
graphics in the kernel that graphics
appears to be inert but generates
caching information that allows the
front-end to that that has generated the
placement information or than the the
kind of the generated graphics
primitives to do all of these various
call-outs and things your comments on
that I I don't know enough about what's
actually being done by Raymond I mean so
for the visualization you know current
placement stuff right it's very specific
to points lines you know starting to get
into polygons and surfaces but it's not
necessarily general-purpose and it's not
necessarily the case that if you have
you know that it's set up for labeling a
mixture of things okay fine so there's
two different issues here
look engineering wise this is not going
to go on the front end anytime soon it's
just too complicated we don't want it
there therefore we have to have some
kind of you know caching you know
transport cache so to speak that's thing
number one thing number two you're
saying and there is more development
work to do if we want to fully support
an arbitrary mixture of graphics
primitives with arbitrary labels and
call-outs that correct
okay fine but we can get we can get
somewhere you know the Oviatt we can do
the obvious thing easily but then we
have to build a framework that involves
this transport cache to be able to
let these things be computed in the
kernel and then sent to the front-end
yeah well I wonder if they mean hey
they're full graphics or maybe some
other function right so we can have like
literalized graphics types function
which goes and searches for things which
require and sort of invokes all of the
visualization logic to stick them you
know sure but but we don't want that at
a user level at a user level the person
should just use labeled in a graphics
we're not going to have a big long
discussion about whether they know
whether the thing is happening in the
kernel or the front end it's irrelevant
because in a in a you know theoretically
conceptually all this stuff like axes is
resolved in that you know should be
thought of as conceptually resolved in
the renderings today stage right we know
I I mean I don't think I mean III I
don't think that's necessarily true I
mean people rely on the graphics
language to represent you know the
graphics and if we're going to sort of
suddenly transform it into something
else okay right one of the complaints
about Geographics is that you can't
really apply the you know the the sort
of you can't do the same sort of
processing on it that you can on
graphics like what right you eat you
can't just sort of insert points or sort
of manipulate entities right because
there it has the what do you mean you
you've got it has Geographics has its
own interpretation of what points and
polygons and so on mean in the context
of geo coordinates and so on right and
you can't really manipulate that what do
you mean by mean you have to rely on
sort of what kind of manipulation are we
talking about I mean you're talking
about taking the symbolic expression and
doing something to it right right okay
well you can do that it's just that so
are you saying that Geographics actually
evaluates to something different
graphics actually evaluates I see which
is just may have been called Geographics
but
okay but I mean let's so if I say
something like this I'm Bochy I'm gonna
say point of that right right um and
then I say something like polygon of 1s
is it doing what is it doing
oh there we go okay so and you're saying
if I now look at the input form of that
that it's gonna be some shoe what the
heck is it what's it doing it's got a
huge bitmap in it Wow
okay right input its graph you know Co
graphics as graphics excuse me excuse me
what on earth is this an input form wise
why is this numeric array not showing up
as a compressed data object it's in
perform doesn't do that right never has
right if you if you had unformatted the
cell you would see compressed data but
okay who asks for the input form okay
all right okay okay okay so Geographics
is an example of exactly this thing
where it is doing in this case it's
doing evaluation as opposed to a caching
thing right right
okay which I'm not advocating for
graphics I'm advocating invisible
caching I'm not advocating evaluation
it's some okay so yeah comment on our
live stream from Lucas is with the
hidden cache thing it'll be hard to
manipulate the rendered call outs
although a full graphics is fixed that
would be a way to do it I agree
um and Brian our live stream by the way
says agrees with many of us that if you
say I want leaders on my call outs you
should get leaders on the call house um
the okay well look I think that
okay so rapping I think we can more or
less wrap this up because I think what
we want to do is study the possibility
of a transport cache and study what it
would take to generalize the labeling
and call out stuff to deal with
arbitrary collections of graphics
primitives but fair
that's for bread
so not all for Brett I mean part of part
of this is for John because it has to do
with how we would do the the you know
this transport cash and by the way if we
did the transport cash approach then
we'll immediately get the cloud version
working - John can you comment on like I
don't properly understand what what a
transport cache here is so what I mean
by that is you type graphics okay
the kernel will do an evaluation pass on
that it will and I don't know exactly
the right way to do it I mean there are
variety of functions that have cash
caches like rule for example has caches
that are not visible so my Titan I'm
sorry now if that rule does not but it
hasn't for several versions how does
that work now is it a weak hash table or
something what is it how does it work I
guess I guess if you if you actually use
it in a replacement and yes it'll be a
weak a stable okay fine so it's a dis
it's a disconnected cache in that case
but so my point is to have an invisible
cash that is transportable through the
front row it doesn't necessarily have to
be invisible I mean it could be added as
an option in the graphics right that
then it's transported to the front end
the front end uses that to effectively
add in additional primitives that
corresponds to that you know those those
the labeling stuff okay well I you know
it depends on the complexity of what
we're doing around that but I mean in
principle yes the sort of thing you're
talking about is not unreasonable I mean
I think it might that you know some
things that I worry about things like
selection working correctly in the
graphic although frankly that's not
widely used but I mean I think that will
be a question of just exactly how that
cache looks and how it encapsulates well
yeah I mean how does selection work with
something like this
by the way does selection work in a
reasonable way here I mean if I go then
probably not because there's dynamics
involved yeah well I mean that one's
probably fine that's kind of interesting
I'm amazed that that works Wow it's
probably partially luck that's
encouraging that's really cool that that
works I mean it would be nice if that
worked you know and in fact this relates
to I don't know what that what is going
on okay that that's okay so you know it
does what it does
um not unreasonable so that selection
was okay now this selection what happens
if I try to do this selection here
those are dynamics and so their selves
you know if you manage to move them okay
even if I move the center it just it
just beeps at me okay there about why
it's beeping okay
I don't remember setting them not
editable but it may have been something
I don't think people expect this to work
although it's another thing that we
should put on the list as a possible as
something possible um but okay so anyway
my recommendation is this transport
cache idea and and so then the concert
your potential consequence of this would
be that graphics of something involving
labels may take three seconds that's
correct that's correct I mean it's it's
got to be computed somewhere right right
so the alternative is it fails and does
nothing and produces a pink box which I
don't think is particularly useful you
know people may be surprised if they
have some very complicated graphic with
10,000 you know points in it and they
all have labels and they've all got to
compute their avoidance algorithm they
may be surprised that slow but then I've
got a beautiful graphic out and maybe
they'll figure out well how it was slow
there um I mean you know in a perfect
world as we're going towards
or kind of immediate feedback having
something where you have a little slider
that says computing labeling you know
what are these progress indicators that
says you know computing labeling or
something right ugly thing to do if
indeed you get into that three-second
situation right all right anything more
to say in this meeting so coming back to
highlighted yes which you had brought up
and you wanted it to sort of puff out
well I don't do did I want it to puff
out I mean
remind me what highlight if you go back
to that other notebook that you know
contains the snippet from your email yes
that should highlighted work oh I suit
and what we're saying so for example I
see what it was saying so if I say
something like let's see I want to say
here's what I'm trying to say so I'm
trying to say something like you know
countries in turn antal Europe and then
I say something like here so obviously
if I were to select out of this
something like Monaco right um and I
would say for example let me do this
let's whoops I want I want to take this
and I would say here I'm trying to think
what this is going to do but but let's
say I say for Monica was Monaco there we
go I say style um red okay and now I say
Geographics of this so don't think it's
gonna do anything let's go show you
Europe but not oh I should have said
style polygon Monaco red right right
okay so the problem with that is okay
wow this is really slow why is it so
slow today it's crazy is it broken up
you know I and something that's wrong
there's something wrong and somebody
should try and figure out what it is
because I've had you know several things
here that were
okay so let's let's prune down list
dramatically
okay that [ __ ] doesn't really matter
actually all we need to do is that and
then say um plot range zero range arrow
okay so you'll see what the problem is
here um so in the promised Monica is
tiny yeah I mean well let's see what
they okay so we don't see Monaco here
right so my issue is if I said
highlighted at Monaco I would like that
to work
oh it's what's the mechanism to do you
know how do I get something where I can
see it I can see Monaco here I'm not
sure what the mechanism is okay but what
I might expect would work is to say
highlighted right instead of staying
style read say highlighted at Monaco in
other words if I say Gio list plot you
know I could do the same thing I could
say GLS plot of um you know this play
the better case I'd say journalist plot
of just Monaco but now if I say here
that that's the case that I wanted I
wasn't I was confused I see yeah I was
confused so this is the case that I want
is um style Monaco there and this and
I'm not gonna be able to see it right
there it is I can't see it right right
so what I would like to be able to do is
to say highlighted at Monaco and have it
be somehow visible I'm not sure what the
right mechanism for making it visible is
but you know that's that's the idea
right well I mean it's the problem that
it's not actually making it read or that
we can't see that it's red we can't see
it
you know if
gets rid of the Geo range then it'll be
you know nice now that'll be absolutely
fine but but that's not the point the
point is that there is here where you
want to be able to see you know you say
I don't shape okay well there it is um
they okay so great he doesn't know where
it is yes no I don't know where it is
all right so right but I get the point
I'm trying to make is does it I mean is
this something where you're using the
wrong tool and you want to be using you
know no good right I don't see how you
know blowing you know blowing it up by
an arbitrary amount I mean they don't
see no I don't think blowing it up is
sufficient I think it is going to need
to turn into a call-out of some kind
because here's the thing that I did okay
so for example I'm showing a map of you
know what countries have signed the
such-and-such treaty okay and it looks
like Oh nobody in Europe has signed that
treaty
well actually Monaco did but I can't see
that because on the map the the you know
you know maybe China did and it's a
great big blob on the map but I don't
see Monaco on the map right that's the
case I'm trying to deal with and so that
is more of a and information
visualization thing where you might want
some little you know the other thing all
out your an inset map oh that's a
different thing I think that's more
elaborate I wasn't thinking of something
less elaborate I mean I was thinking
here so if I say call out of this what
the heck is that
well then you you you gave it red and
ago so it's trying to type sad red know
if that's interesting fill your mood
yeah but right if you did like you know
foo whatever right yeah yeah I'm not
sure I think that's a bug that's about I
mean it's definitely a bug we're just
trying to figure the basic point is we
want a mechanism for um
let's see um we want a mechanism that
allows you to show that there is a thing
there even though it is too small to see
right
I was imagining highlighted could
usefully do I mean it's a right right
but they think that the workflow you
were suggesting is I mean you don't know
that you're not going to see Monica
right what they think that's really a
visual is it right I think that's really
a visualization function we need to make
it smarter so or you know either by a
value plot so let's for example um geo
reagent value plot mm-hmm you know it is
not smart about this you know in other
words if let's say we're plotting you
know countries with GDP per capita
rather above this right it's just open
there's nothing there and wherever but
actually there's Singapore or something
is there but it's too small see right I
mean actually I think for excuse me it's
possible that geo list plot is not being
clever enough I mean so if you in that I
think it may be hardwiring countries
into polygons
whereas cities have the ability these
ability to switch from a polygon
representation to a point representation
based on scale and how close things are
and how big they are and that sort of
thing nice what you're saying so this
could be switching to a point
representation of the country which
would then be visible right right which
is what I was trying to say right that I
mean the problem you're describing is
that I want to highlight this point is I
want to make the visualization function
smaller smarter so it automatically
makes small things visible yes Brett is
saying that that's already been done for
cities that the city would show like for
example if I were to yeah in fact
basically what you're saying is there's
maybe a bug so maybe it's just a bug
because this is a country right are you
saying that as a city are you saying it
might work differently that will be
crazy crazy well no if you do cheerless
plugs
sorry Sammy or in Orlando and
Tallahassee okay let's do this
Miami hole and oh those are very close
together mm-hmm
see I know a tiny bit of geography and
Tallahassee I can't even spell let's try
Gainesville I think I can spell that
okay um so you get Florida and I think
those will all be polygons why is this
so slow what is going on here so some
issue that geoserver okay so those are
all polygons right and now add San Diego
to the list okay
minimize by typing what is going on
something is wrong here
can we Tsushima could you get somebody
to try and look at this I don't know
what this is I'm guessing it's a
containing the examples at the same time
they are faster for me I wonder where
they it's because of this zoom session
yeah I don't think so I don't think so
well it may be some other issue with my
network in which case the problem
question for Roger okay
what the heck let's take in a really
long time you're even for the other ones
we've seen what is going on all right
let's try one one more time and then
we'll well okay but you're telling me
that what this is doing is to put points
for all those cities correct okay well
so maybe that's just maybe and why is it
choosing to do that and not choosing to
do that for countries maybe that's just
a pure bug I mean I think it was sort of
you know historical how geo this plot
was developed and all right so then
maybe this is a bug that they're
basically what we should do is we should
say that there's a minimum size where a
polygonal thing will get turned into a
point with this because imagine
one of these world polygons in which we
have like 10,000 Islands if they all get
now converted into points it's not going
to look correct you're right about that
but but that's but if you specifically
mention these islands in the journalist
plot I mean you know in other words we
have a way of you know we have an
explicit way but I don't understand that
comment actually Jose I don't understand
that
why are you could whoever's typing
please mute themselves sorry but um so
this is a an alias an ally anti-aliasing
thing so so when you have very many
islands if they are all points they they
look like bigger than these should be
think that the smaller ones are not
visible yeah that's right but if you but
if you explicitly ask for them I mean if
they're in the base map so to speak you
don't want them to be explicitly visible
but if you explicitly ask for them then
surely you should be seeing them right
yes yes if there are a few a fury I do
not know what is going on with my system
here this is really weird
yeah anybody I'm just gonna try this I
mean I just evaluated that input I'm
gonna send you a screenshot so you can
yeah okay now it worked okay so I get
what's happening here so I mean okay so
you're telling me basically that I mean
if I did this in Europe for example I
mean I think we only have polygons for
US cities at the moment no okay I
understand I understand I understand but
I'm saying that if I were to combine
cities and countries whose Sakana ding
on the color what's what's wrong with
the color right that that they're all
red oh that's fun ok another book
okay but but okay so look it seems to me
that the bug is simply if you explicitly
mention an object and it is going to be
too small to see you should put a point
there and we may want some control over
that I mean it is conceivable that even
in this case here that you might want to
simply not see these things if they're
too small
easy right and we've made the choice to
make them into points which I agree is
the typical default that we'd want but
um the right yeah
Brian our live stream is commenting on
actually making inset maps will be
really cool for certain cases or at
least having the option to do that and
that it would be its own Jose in my list
okay fine I don't I don't think it's on
a list that I've ever seen but okay so
look it seems like we should just
investigate this and they may just be a
bug here right as you say you're gonna
want some control over it because you
won't necessarily want to point for
Monaco if everything in Europe is lit up
already
sorry I didn't understand that comment
right I mean so if you have you know
polygon for Italy and a polygon for
France and whatever you may not actually
need what do you mean in that case the
problem is look I mean in that case of
polygon for Monaco may be enough you
know instead of having a you know this
weird little point floating right but
particularly in geo value plot co-regent
value plots it's sort of disastrous to
have a region you can't see okay so here
if I say style Monaco or this is not
gonna work are you telling me that star
Monaco green or something right actually
I don't even need to say that I'm just
kind of see what is going on here what
is going on whatever okay so know Monaco
we can't see it great
so that's what I think is wrong I think
Monaco should be showing up and I don't
know what the right position is on this
map I don't think a red dot is the right
to fault them that's a different thing
to talk about in terms of styling I mean
probably it would still be a dot but it
would be a yellowy orange e dot I would
think so
but I think it's useful in this case see
it's so difficult to say you might not
want to show up or you might want it to
show up in geo region value plot you
definitely I think Union I think the
default okay I'm gonna make the claim
default for G region value plot is to
make it show up the default in geo list
plot is probably not to make it show up
anybody want to comment on that I think
the default is to make it show up in
both cases okay but I think we do need
an option to control it so that it's
kind of the the real size version of the
graphic right as opposed to the kind of
info based version of you know sizing I
can reach in region value plot we use
tooltips for the value rate yes so we
will be color things according to the
value right you get color and you get
the tooltip right I see you know yeah
but you need to be able to see it in
order to know that yeah and go over it
to see the tooltip exactly and if the
values are not necessarily numeric then
well that's a completely separate
discussion okay right we should wrap
this meeting but okay so we've got a
number of things to follow up on here
all right thanks all very much thank you
to the folks on livestream see you next
time actually there are next time is
there one later today or is it no
tomorrow
well and also tomorrow is the first of
our versions of marketing page twitch
sessions so which one is it
asymptotics me and Devendra will be
presenting on asymptotics okay so so
and Brett and speaking of visualization
Brett will be talking about complex
visualization on Thursday complex-valued
visualization yes to be clear great okay
tomorrow it looks like we have entity
type entity ontology discussion as a
live stream okay see y'all soon see